相邦相邦
今天头发长度很高哦
很蓬松
时差哈哈哈
七早八早上起来
你怎么现在还在时差啊
哦那没时差
我第二天第三天才开始吗
哦底袋时差就是尼康百
Oh long time
No
See
我们美国小分队回来啦
跟大家团聚啦
美国小分队时差调回来了没有
应该很多
还没吧
OK今天晚上好
要睡觉
这侧脸有点认不出
祝你快半拍跳快乐
爱莎
100分很好
继续证明你们没有时差
♪ 女爱是最甜美丽 ♪
♪ 呼唤小怪都好 ♪
可傻哥叫你甜蜜的你你先把这个给他
要怪真真的给他一个大头三次不对啊
因为我们那个美国小分队海鸥飞行的猫阿德
因为身高太高
站位的关系
他没有去
所以现在回归了
还有飞行的高的那个角色
角色对
回归了啊
但是我们又要开始伤脑筋了
要怎么样啊
好好给他处理处理想你
我听到叮叮铃将所有的坏天交给我
然后我们就开始上进心交给他之后
然后就不管他了
好好好好新他们在大堂里冰峰看到的库里
看到佛山从上一次来的时候就很热情
然后又是我们呃这个冬季庆典的一个开始
这样所以今天我们要圆满
继续圆满热情的把佛山给嗨爆他们
佛山佛山梨树靠山
佛山休克黑甜度登乐山
啊啊啊啊哦哦哦哦哦哦哦哦哦
上人家很大哦
哦这有意义不行
还有两滴泪
看几分了
他们他们居然还没开始喊他呢
还没开始喊上班呢
五六哦
五六很难怪
♪ 爱很easy很ea easy ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ 心情很easy很easy ♪
♪ woo o o梦很easy很easy ♪
♪ 耶耶耶 ♪
♪ 笑一笑 ♪
♪ 没什么大不了 ♪
欢迎来suki party
♪ Cindy ♪
让你伤心
怎么可以
♪ CINDY心里有快递 ♪
♪ 咿呀咿呀哟 ♪
我大学四年我也是学了
学了一点点
我们有尸骨意啊
我们北体有一个是湿骨意
我上课有认真学
老师你看到了吗
请放一下我刚才的片段
♪ 海浪来吧 ♪
我还有彩妆
你有注意到吗
我的脚要踩那个阶梯
我本来想要跳的
我要是本来转身要叫地瓜进到我的后面
呵呵来不及
没有时间沟通
这种东西可以先彩排的
今天是SUGHAI2.0的第70一场演唱会了
我觉得我的伙伴们大家都很棒
可以他们给他们掌声鼓励
我们
这一场巡演呢其实也慢慢慢慢的走向尾声了
每一次站上舞台
看到你们的笑容
我都觉得很珍贵
每一次听到你们呼喊上班或是加班
我都还是觉得很可爱
我们一起经历了这样可爱的
一场又一场的演唱会
但我觉得这个不是告别
我想下一次的演唱会应该不会让大家等太久的
在那之前
我们都要好好照顾自己
好不好
我们都要在心里头照顾彼此的心
♪ 跳 ♪
宠爱我们就要就要一天天慢慢的死掉
One two three